before I introduce mrs. Clinton I'd like
to begin by introducing congressman
Bernard Sanders of Vermont congressman
Sanders and I would like to introduce a
graduate of Yale who is a very good
friend
it was a very good friend of Dartmouth
and that's our congressman
representative dick sweat thank you
thank you very much don't take too much
time away from the first lady I want to
be very brief I do realize that Yale was
nice enough to let Dartmouth win this
year so but I want to say just just a
couple of things number one I want to
thank Dartmouth and especially president
Friedman for making this visit of the
first lady's so productive and so warm
and so welcoming and it's really a
tribute to the student population as
well as to the faculty and the
administration that you could set such a
wonderful place as the northern New
Hampshire town of hanover to welcome
someone who has done such tremendous
work in health care reform as the first
lady I have had a great deal of
experience with Yale it goes back a long
time but I've also had some experience
with the administration and you know i
might say with my tongue firmly planted
in my cheek that i have sometimes been a
thorn in the side of the administration
I want the first lady to understand I
love and respect everything that the
president and she has done they have
encouraged me to views open and very
honest debate and there's nothing better
for removing thorns and sides than a
little health care reform that's why I'm
announcing today that I'm going to be
the hundred and first co-sponsor of the
president's health care reform package
it's an honor to do so I'm very pleased
and proud to be associated with such
credible and important work that the
administration is carrying forward and
I'm very grateful for the opportunity to
be here with the first lady today to
listen to her tell you me and the rest
of the world why this is so important to
this country lastly for the press I will
be out on the balcony at Alumni Hall
right after this we can talk about my
decision and my plans at that time thank
you very much
in February 1992 mrs. Clinton spoke at
Dartmouth and into hindman forum in the
Rockefeller Center and announced on that
day that if governor clinton was elected
president she would return to speak at
dartmouth she is today keeping that
promise we are delighted to welcome mrs.
Clinton for a second time to Dartmouth
and we hope that you'll be here many
many more times besides Hillary Rodham
Clinton
thank you thank you all thank you so
much this is such a treat I had looked
forward to coming back to Dartmouth and
it gives me such a real thrill to be
here with you although I have to correct
president Friedman for the second time
today earlier earlier he introduced me
and said I had been at Dartmouth back in
February of 92 for my second visit and
that was my first visit this is my
second visit and I told the crowd then
that that doesn't count all the visits I
used to make to Dartmouth when I was at
Wellesley back in the back in the far
distant past when
in fact I remember I remember my very
first visit to Dartmouth I came up for
some kind of meeting that Dartmouth was
holding and I also came for winter
carnival but that was later this was for
the meeting and I came to the meeting
and the meeting was being run and we
were all being organized by Bobby Rice
who is still organizing America one of
your most distinguished alums and the
Secretary of Labor and I will never
forget we had this incredible discussion
and that was before there any women at
Dartmouth at least in the college and so
I must say that I had never had a better
time those of us who came to this
meeting that Bobby Rush put on because
there were about ten of us and about 400
of you also it was great but it is it's
a real treat to be back and especially
for this occasion because what we are
trying to do is to make good on what we
said during the campaign when so many of
you here at the college worked for my
husband's candidacy both in the primary
and then in the general election because
you shared with us what we saw as a real
historic opportunity a chance to begin
to deal with a lot of the problems in
our country a chance to have a new
vision of what it would mean to be a
strong productive America in the 21st
century how we could ensure that this
country which has given us all so much
would continue to provide the
opportunity that you deserve to have and
in the past year we have worked very
hard to build on that vision and we're
very proud of the record of legislative
accomplishment and the changes that have
already begun I don't think there is any
program that is dearer to the
president's heart and in which he feels
more promise than the national service
bill which was passed and signed into
law which will begin next year providing
opportunities for young people to do
national service and for thousands to
begin to finance their way through
college because they're willing to do
service to America that's what a new
America vision means but part of what
still lies before us
is to tackle a problem that is really
one that has developed over decades but
which threatens to undermine one of the
strongest parts of our national heritage
there isn't any doubt that America has
the finest medical system in the world
if you can afford to use it if you can
get there if you can take advantage of
what it has to offer there's also no
doubt that for those who are well
insured there is a certain sense of
being taken care of but increasingly
even for those of us who are insured
there is no security every month 2.25
million Americans lose their health
insurance and usually they lose it
because they change jobs or they're laid
off or the business they were working
for no longer will provide health care
but sometimes it's because all of a
sudden they can't be insured because
they've got an illness or a child has a
problem that nobody wants to take care
of and so even for those of us who are
insured there isn't any real health
security and what the president is
absolutely committed to doing is
providing health care reform that first
and foremost gives every one of you the
absolute confidence that no matter who
you work for no matter where you live no
matter whether you have a pre-existing
condition which is insurance language
for having been sick and maybe still
having something you have to take care
of like diabetes that you will always
always be able to afford to have your
health care needs met I'm very grateful
for the leadership that many people are
giving to this great reform effort and
I'm grateful that congressman Sanders
would join us today from Vermont and I
am particularly pleased the congressman
sweat would announce his endorsement of
the health care reform the health
security act today here at his home
state but you know there has been
efforts in the past to reform our health
care system
this is not a problem that is new back
in the days of your grandparents and
great-grandparents Franklin Roosevelt
thought that he would do social security
which would lift millions and millions
of Americans and their older years out
of abject poverty and then he would do
health security but he couldn't get it
done and then President Truman came
along and in 1945 he said we have to
make sure that every person in America
has health insurance no matter what
their race or their residents or their
economic statuses but he tried in 1945
he tried in 1947 and he couldn't get it
done because there were so many
interests that said why do we need to do
that we don't need to worry about that
now and then in the 1960s President
Johnson was able to get through both
Medicare and Medicaid to programs that
have made a huge difference in the lives
of millions of Americans many of your
grandparents my parents were on Medicare
which enabled them to deal and my
father's last days with very severe
hospitalization and medical costs and
knowing that they wouldn't have to sell
their house they wouldn't go bankrupt
they'd have to pay something but it
wasn't going to destroy what they had
saved all those years and now we know
that the changes that were made then
made this a more humane and better
society for the very poor and for the
elderly President Nixon tried to get
health care reform through in the early
1970s and again it didn't go anywhere
now is the time yes there will be great
discussion in our country for the next
month's and I'm thrilled to see some of
these signs where clearly people are and
the campuses around America becoming
involved and interested in what health
care security will mean to them I
remember very well when I was in college
I didn't think about health insurance it
wasn't something that was on the top of
my mind I didn't realize that you know I
might need it someday and it wasn't
really until I was married and probably
not really until I was apparent that I
began to understand what it would mean
to
if I didn't have health insurance and
what it means to millions of Americans
every day just want to tell you just a
very few little stories that may reflect
something of your own experience about
why this is important for everybody
because remember what we are trying to
do is not just to take care of those
people who get up every day and go to
work I bet some of your families fall
into this category but they don't make
quite enough money to be able to afford
insurance and their employers don't help
them they are uninsured yes we're going
to make sure every American is insured
but the only way we can do that is by
ensuring that every American always has
health care benefits I don't want in the
next year's to go around our country and
to talk to the people I've talked with
with the stories they have to tell me i
sat in the living room of a small
farmhouse in Iowa with four farm
families who opened their books to show
me what it costs them to try to keep
health insurance and try to make a
living on the farm there was one family
because the father had had an accident
on the farm and one of their children
had diabetes they were paying nine
thousand dollars a year for health
insurance that was as much as they made
from their farm on some years and I've
been in New Orleans talking to people
who've worked all their lives for the
same company but never could afford
insurance I've had a woman look at me
and say I've worked here 15 years and
I've always tried to take care of myself
and every year I go and get a physical
and I pay for it out of my own pocket
because I want to stay healthy but last
year she said the doctor found a lump in
my breast and sent me to the surgeon the
surgeon said you know if you had
insurance we would biopsy it but since
you don't why don't we just watch it and
I thought to myself what if that had
been me or my mother or my friend and
I've talked to small business people who
can't get insurance in today's market
without paying an exorbitant amount of
money because we discriminate against
small business people and I've looked at
a mother and a father who had left their
jobs where they had insurance because
they wanted to start a small business
but
they couldn't afford insurance and the
mother said she had told her two sons
don't play sports this year boys because
if he get hurt we can't afford it and
I've talked to another small business
person who ensures his family and his
four employees and their family and then
all of a sudden one of his longtime
employees had a child with Down syndrome
like the young man whose hand I shook as
I was coming through the corridor
they're working here making his
contribution to Dartmouth but this man
when he was faced with the insurance
company that said you know we're gonna
have to raise your rates really high
because you've got this employee with a
Down Syndrome child and my friend said
well what can I do about that and the
agent said way you can fire him that
shouldn't be a choice anybody has to
make those are the stories that are made
every day in America that move us to say
we can do better than this we know this
is the smartest richest strongest best
nation in the world in solving problems
and it's about time we put our minds to
work and solve this one and once we
solve it we will have provided health
security for every American no matter
who they are where they live who they
work for or whatever happens to them but
we would have done something else we
would have made a statement about what
our values are as a people we would have
said that you know it's time we got back
to taking care of each other in this
country it's time we viewed each other
as members of a great extended community
and where some of us maybe can help out
a little bit to make sure people get
taken care of we want to do that because
there but for the grace of God go you or
I so this is a debate about health care
and i hope you will read this book which
is going to be in the library will be in
the bookstore and i'll give this to
president friedman to have available but
more than that i hope you will think
about what we are trying to achieve in
our country and what opportunities there
are for your generation to be engaged in
making sure we are always always on the
cutting edge of change and promise and
possibility
that America lives up to its promise to
you the way it did for me and my husband
thank you all very much
mrs. Clinton on behalf of all of
Dartmouth students I'd like to present
you with this gift
thank you
well thank you president Friedman and I
want to give you these copies and I want
to assure you that we cannot get this
done without the big green behind us so
you all got to be there